this is a tough one Harry Kane versus
Cristiano
Ronaldo oh I've got the I've got I think
I've got the answer I think we're pretty
two one
Ronaldo you're useless me what's wrong
with you there's something wrong with
you right without further Ado let's get
straight into it we've got the first
bracket we're going do it on your side R
we have got Alan Shir I'm worried about
him I'm just got to flag it you know
when you partnered this up yeah I'm like
I give this the due diligence that it
deserves I'm taking this incredibly
seriously I'm going to play this by the
book I'm going to remove all tribalism
all bias I'm just going to do this
correctly no Chelsea play you and you
see what I mean see
what one chelse some point well you got
you only got two to be fair as a man
city they're great amazing very recent
anyone no nobody nobody from your 2000
team where's Paul dick off yeah Paul
dick about to say where's Paul dick off
Sean go on it I one
CH amazing right starting up here let's
start up here Shar versus
Rooney should we just just explore who
they are right so you got 260 Premier
League goals which is so impressive so
significant bearing in mind that he was
doing it for a team that wasn't the
greatest it's all very well to talk
about talk about Wayne Rooney's
brilliant I'm sure we'll come on to that
but 260 for a team that didn't win any
silver well largely for a team that
didn't win any silverware you know after
he had the successes at at blackb Rovers
and his brief time at Southampton no
trophies and yet he was still pinging
him in but if you look at the Rooney
debate if you put Rooney into the
Blackburn side in in 95 you put Rooney
into the Newcastle side that he was
there for 15 years Alan Shar does he
score 260 goals I think he does Shar
played up front every single game Rooney
had to play left wing right wing had to
drop into Midfield at the back end of
his career Rooney's a better footballer
than she better better to Total
footballer you could also say he scored
a Champions League final goal for Man
United they yeah but it's still a goal
give back to Lampard no no no you you l
no you sneered at me about I told you
about Lampard going the CH final goal
your answer to me is you didn't win it
that's true yeah that is true yeah I
just look Sher just didn't have that
Legacy he had a few seasons in the
championship with with with Bobby Robson
of course but I just think Rooney I have
I have to stick with Rooney if you want
to go hard on Sher you can have it it's
a shame that we're comparing these two
because I would have definitely had
these two further into the debate but
we've been throwing random generator by
the way we've is it totally random
generator totally random yeah yeah
yeah sure why Dr was H yeah okay um I
look Rooney's a better footballer Ro
Rory go England go right England top
goal scorer Manchester United top goal
scorer countless amounts of silverware
arguably the best British footballer
that has ever been created it's Rooney
it's Rooney yeah okay you want to ConEd
that definitely I want moment to Big Al
I feel I feel slightly I feel slightly
harsh that we're uh leaving the top goal
scorer of the Premier League era off of
he's gone out he's gone out so early but
just the luck of the draw right Rooney's
through all right nice next one we have
got Taron re versus D Dr don't stop he
giving me a funny look already no man
you're gonna have to re like you you've
got a role here you're the Arbiter you
you've got a significant like presence
here and he's going to play not
physically
but you're Aura Aura okay I like that I
like that okay I I'll I'll be on I'll
help okay I'm in the middle go on I'll
go on should we just explore onry at
least because HRI is the second best
striker in the history of the Premier
League I think drba is the best striker
in the history of Chelsea Football Club
that's a big difference I don't think J
gets into top five in the Premier League
era he hasn't he hasn't got that kind of
the Premier League icon status he scored
that goal against Munich in the
Champions League but in the Premier
League era when we seeing HRI run
through a whiteart lane and all that
these big goals in the Premier League
era has to be tier HRI so talk about big
gay moments you're allowing that yeah
sorry I was looking for you to do sorry
you're just moving on from that no no
talking about big game moments who do
you think is the bigger player in those
moments in terms of that conversation
there is no debate here like Freddy lber
is a better big game player for Arsenal
and T re like that that's a fact T re
when it most mattered went through
one-onone in Paris and missed D dropper
when it most mattered dragged Chelsea to
to not only the Champions League it's
it's what 10 finals nine goals like in
terms of in terms of doing it and doing
it and doing it well it's DDA drba we
sneer at
drogba's goal record overall but 20 2010
Chelsea won the double yeah did jba
scored a ridiculous amount of goals
ridiculous amount of assists you know
people go you know he didn't score the
goals he didn't ever have that season
2010 he had it what what are the numbers
so he's yeah 2010 we've got here 29
goals that season premier league 29
Premier League that's amazing and
overall that season cuz we won the
double so overall how many goals they
drop 37 mate 37 goals in in a double
winning season if you give me a total
striker in big games Champions League FA
Cup finals League Cup finals what can I
say there's no debate it's drba HRI
didn't even score a goal in a final in
his whole career but in the Premier
League League debate which this is what
it is hry is an icon of the Premier
League he's an advertisement to who more
Premier Leagues uh by one drba I'm
guessing something like that by
one many so yeah but but as an
advertisement to someone watching in
America someone watching in South
America uh the Premier League HRI is an
icon he's top three icons in the history
of the league whether you think you know
it's probably Rooney but we need to be
better than that we need to see beyond
iconic status we need to we need to we
need to be a little bit more critical
right yeah Prestige and Prestige and
beauty and and Majesty absolutely it's
all TI on R yeah but Striker Champions
League final but striker in the Premier
League Striker to win the Premier League
in the final better goal to game ratio
in one of the greatest sides of all time
in the in the Invincible okay one okay
better than the doubles the double so
I'm going have to push you so are you
agreeing disagree the thing is very
difficult for me here because I know
that in this room if and I reckon that
this room is a case study for the world
everybody disagrees with me I I know
that I'm fighting and losing battle here
and therefore I'm going to concede and
put tiar on re because I know that's
what the sport Bible audience will have
done I know that's what the comments
will be suggesting I just wanted to
really fight it because I don't think
people acknowledge his
contribution by look no doubt don't
worry about it it's cherry on re Cherry
go through no big deal yeah done anyway
moving on I should have got you on that
side of it right look at that t HRI has
made it through okay next one we got
Michael versus
Cole they're both incredible Strikers on
their day obviously Michael Owen winning
the Balon door Andy Cole has the
Champions League he's got the the treble
winners of 99 uh even the back end of
his career he sort of stayed in the
Premier League played for like Fulham
Man City few other clubs in in there as
well so his goal record in the league is
fantastic you I think it's an easy one
in terms of Andy Cole but Michel Owen's
level I think you could argue Micha
Owen's level the season before he goes
to Real Madrid or just before that even
in the '90s is maybe a little bit higher
than Andy Cole in a single season
overall I think the answer here has to
be Andy Cole
but like the very definition of
generation or Michael Owen when he C
when he bursts onto the scene it it blew
my mind for for England and Liverpool
pre the age of about 22 23 it was it was
unlike anything I've ever seen but the
answer has to be Andy K all right nice
and easy okay next one we've got Dennis
bur versus Lis Suarez we I don't think
bur's a good goal scorer is he good
finisher like he could finish a chance
he wasn't that kind of strong
talk about General play goals of course
might be the easiest one on the list and
because I think Suarez's range of goals
his his ability to strike the ball any
kind of range free kicks all sorts one
of the the best strikers to ever play in
the league his time is concentrated so I
think his legacy is slightly diminished
never won the Premier League obviously
burd count was part of the invincibles
um I think Suarez is actually relatively
easy I see I can see Rory chomping at
the bit here we've got a problem we've
got we've got a real problem because as
passionate and one-sided as boovie was
there about Suarez I feel about Burham I
think the answer to this is Dennis
Burham I think Dennis burkham is
possibly the most gifted footballer on
this on this entire board I think that's
how good he is he is like a truly
Sensational player a premier league
great one of the most natural finishers
that you could ever want to find
yourself with in your team but because
he did so many other things because he
was so good at so much maybe we don't
see him as a finisher but he some some
of the best goals that you will ever see
are Dennis burken goals sometimes and
this isn't even a joke when I used to
work in an office
if you know that half hour period where
you coming towards the end of the day
and you've had your second coffee you
don't really know what to do with your
time you're pretending to work I would
often just put on Dennis Burham goals
like that's how good you are just watch
Dennis Burham score like eight goals and
watch the watch the replays and then
it's time to go home like that's a
wonderful way to end every day he is as
ruthless a finisher as you could ever
want to find in your team it's just he
does so much more I think Suarez has
some of the most unique range of
finishes of anyone on this board but I'm
I'm happy to give it to bur Camp he's
actually won the Premier League I think
that's important yeah I think that's I
think that has to be brought into into
account and and he was partly Invincible
wasn't he just watch his goals at filber
Street just put in Arsenal Leicester
Filbert Street and then you go oh Rory
was
right we'll look it in we'll look it in
love that right okay we're going to get
on to this side of the draw now we have
got Sergio Aguero versus Mo Salah I see
look at the smile on his face it's hard
because random generator e CH no I I
think uh in football The Narrative
around football's a weird one we forget
and I think we overlook how good Aguero
was the range of finishing his goals to
gain ratio plus the big goals to get
city our first premier league title in
the Premier League era it's it's
undisputable I think he's the best
striker in the history of the league and
in a 442 alltime combined Premier League
era it's him and HRI for me I think it's
as easy as that what was Aguero not good
at like what was his flaw as being a
striker like inside the Box ruthless in
the air despite being about our height
ruthless outside the box lethal left
foot no problem like there wasn't a
floor and there's not many Strikers on
this list where you could say that there
just isn't a floor in their game and
Aguero is certainly that but it's Salah
you did an alltime 11 of of uh Liverpool
I think Mohamad Salah is now in it you
know if they were to go Hansen's in it
and sunnes is in it and dag is in it I
think Salah is in it and not many from
the modern era will be so that's how
good I think muhamad Salah is you look
at his goal return He has become a
premier league great it's just so
difficult that he's up against Aguero
here the Centurion side Aguero started
down the middle for that side the
greatest side mathematically in the
history of the Premier League for me one
of the greatest ever anyway so and
Aguero started that that side you know
he he was imperious That season he's
right he's right but it's Sal in that
case then Sergio Guero 7% of the vote
seven yeah of the whole
whole
not there no no for the whole board 7%
and most Sal only
1% really I'll take that that's
beautiful I suppose because of the
definition of a striker Aguero is a
striker
better baby can you do a the Hors please
really is that is that WI a vote yeah
next one Robin V Percy versus Jamie
vardy the Leicester story transcends
sport I think it's the best story ever
there is something quite uncomfortable
about leaving Robin van pery off of this
though you know that year when he moved
to Manchester United he just won in the
league before Christmas that year his
goals up until Christmas Manchester
United were like it was Chelsea chasing
they were just out of sight all right
the narrative around V is massive it's
it's cinematic in terms of where he came
from but he's a fantastic ruthless
finisher his goals to gain ratio in the
Premier League is incredible he's got
that premier league title as well the
goals were instrumental in that he works
harder than van persy off the ball and I
think he actually he managed the back
end of his career better I think you
know in his early 30s I think van persy
fell off a little bit quicker so you
know it's a hard one it's really hard
okay can we employ democracy yeah to
you're going to split the vote yeah okay
Rob such a cough out right Robin van
persy 2.25% of the vote and Jamie vardy
1.75 wow so very
tight right next one Robbie Fowler
versus erling
Harland well it's a testament to earling
harland's first season in Premier League
football we can even have this debate
he's had one season everyone else here
had what at least six seven in the
Premier League at least if not 10 so uh
har came in he's won of trouble he's
broken all sorts of Records in English
football in European football he's a
better Striker than than Robbie F in
every regard not every he's not a better
finisher he's a better finisher than
Robbie fer definitely he's not a better
ER Holland's overall better player he's
overall a better Striker but he's not
overall Robby F's not scoring hat tricks
in the Champions League Robie F got a
hatrick against Arsenal with five
minutes yeah but in the Champions League
we're seeing him do it for Dortmund when
he was 19 18 years old I mean his his
status is similar to to Mike Owens in
terms of in terms of his Prime and he's
only 22 years I there's one issue with
this I ering Haren is a better
Striker but there's something that
doesn't sit right with me putting in
somebody off the back of one season
putting in somebody who was who is going
to go down as like a premier league icon
we're comparing one SE I think in three
four years time this is a different
conversation but as of today Holland's
Got One season if you put that Holland
player in Liverpool he's scoring the
same kind of goals as Fowler is's he's a
infinitely you put Robie fower in a
Guardiola team he's it in the same is
he's scored 53 goals lastas Robby Fowler
is a finisher the foxing the box aser
called it you you really struggle in
premier league history to find somebody
better at doing that than Robbie F right
I'm going to push you on this
one I
can't Rory's right if we're doing the
legacy of the Premier League what can I
say about Fowler of course one season
Bas it on a play on the player the play
he's a better of course he's a he's
better at everything link up play
physicality I think he works harder than
Fowler off the ball Fowler you just sit
in the Box no am I wrong you're wrong
you are wrong something just doesn't
feel quite correct about putting in
somebody off off the back of one SE one
it's one good season go to the audience
vote it's one it's a generational season
the audience vot is going to be
pointless the V pointless the answer is
Harem I'm intrigued you're going to lock
in Harem lock in but I'm intrig Harland
2% of the vote but Robbie F only .5% of
the vote that's cuz everyone knows their
their their football knowledge they only
gave you 2%
mate next one this is a tough one Harry
Kane versus Cristiano
Ronaldo oh I've got the I've got I think
I've got the answer I think we're pretty
two one
Ronaldo you're useless what's wrong with
you there's something wrong with you
I've actually looked at the board I
wasn't late by you I've spent time I've
been here for half an hour before you
arrived i' looked at the board who is
the Premier League goat a guy won the
Premier League or a guy that came fourth
was happy to get to a cup final at
wembling sit I was giv this a due
diligence that it deserves all last
night I was
studying and the answer is Harry Harry
Kane is better Striker than Cristiano
Ronaldo and the Premier League era yeah
but we can't do that cuz we said about
Salah being you Ed Salah didn't get on
you're that's a good the no but you you
use the Salah argument and you did very
very well and it was close to Aguero you
know you got close to Aguero Ronaldo
wasn't playing as a striker either so
you can't you can't throw that against
Ronaldo positionally how can I sit here
and say Harry Kane's not one of the
greatest Strikers in the Premier League
era of course but we're talking about
goal scorers in the Premier League that
goes on his goals contributed towards
not only Premier League titles some of
the greatest Premier League titles of
all time European cups cups for Man
United three in a row for Man United
goes on to be one of the most expensive
players in the history of football you
know Harry Kane he hasn't got that
lineage in football he doesn't this is
one of the greatest of all time in
football let alone the Premier League
era Kane cannot be out at the first Kane
under Ferguson in ' 08 that man united
side are worse Ronaldo at pochettino's
Tottenham they're better is that fair no
no even if you present it as being fair
I'm asking no it's good it a good try
Fair look I'm staying out of it this is
between you two okay I'm I'm voting Kane
yeah Kane Ronaldo okay we're going to go
to the audience vote so Christian
Ronaldo got
4% Harry Kane
8% wow that's a win that's a win Harry
Kane makes it through surprised by the
4% Harry Kane Harry Kane Harry Kane
could be the answer to this entire
problem that we're solving Cristiano
Ronaldo can't be the answer to this
entire problem that we're solving har
Kane is potentially arguably the
greatest Premier League Striker ever
Cristiano Ronaldo despite his Brilliance
is not potentially the greatest Premier
League Striker ever it's correct well
done sport by the
audience amazing right we're going back
to you now okay Rory we've got Wayne
Rooney versus tiar enri go on then talk
about tierry onri again
now go on you did it once try it again
now well what can I say I mean uh are
you going are you do you know what
you're doing here yet or do we need to
talk about it do you know where you're
going uh I think they both get into a
premier league alltime 11 so if there's
11 players on the pitch there's a couple
of positions up front and slash
attacking Midfield however you want to
do it for War II I think they both start
for me that that that's that's a credit
to both of them yeah I think I think I
probably agree with that
however however we need we now need to
pick one so if you had the opportunity
to have one of these players if one of
these players in their pump could have
played for you in your pump yeah who you
picking my gut is Wayne Rooney yeah
that's my gut he was he was makes
Defenders afraid even if they've got the
ball you what I mean because of what you
could do off of it the physicality
everyone remembers when he shaved his
air he was diving into people at whole
city and all that however however H re
it's harsh in it to leave him leave him
out but then he's got the he's got the
record in the he one more Premier
Leagues even I know I brought up the
Champions League final goal I get it
they lost they lost at Wembley to
Barcelona but hory never even scored
yeah you know the Champions League final
yeah these two are both elite players as
well as goal scorers they are both
Sensational
Ballers who's better better total
footballer you think Rooney's a better
total footb you could stick him in
Midfield you could stick him Center back
he'd be he'd be the best yeah the way he
applies himself the way he could pass
the ball he's a better passer of the
ball get assist brother Carri where
would H he's slower than hry was an
athlete he was quick you know he was
almost a sprinter in terms of how he you
know you could get down the by line I
for me it's Wayne Rooney I I didn't
think I this is you've done very well
here cuz cuz wasn't with you and now
you've done so well so articulate boo
cuz now now now I'm with you right Boo's
[Laughter]
right that's amazing by the way cuz
you've totally convinced me so next one
we've got Andy Cole versus Dennis
buram I think it's pretty easy I think
as you get later into this tournament
that we're doing the goal record for
bird Camp simply isn't there the quality
of goals when he does score fantastic
Andy Andy Cole is a better goal over
there let down he M we're so sorry about
him I know we work together I didn't
anticipate this I'm sorry I'm sorry to
everybody watching I know he's my dear
friend am am I wrong that was a better
goal scorer no better goal game ratio
better Striker burkam was a better total
footballer no bur Hamp is a better stri
we're doing Strikers here bur's a better
stri he never played Striker played off
he played you know you know s buram bur
Camp Le a line this this answer is Ben
it's not it is all right final day of
the season right let's just say it's
Chelsea for argument State you're thr on
goal against West Brom for example final
final day of the season to score a goal
to win the Premier League it's not bur
it's bur count over over Andy Cole it
took him three chances to score one Glen
yeah he's quicker he's a better finisher
he's more powerful he's technically
gifted he'll let he pass it sideways
he'd hit it he hit it true and hard he
pass it sideways he'd ping it in he'd
ping it in Burham ping it in where I've
never I never saw him do those kind of
finishes of course you did no I didn't
then you haven't seen him play enough of
course you can do that I was doing my
work instead of watching highlights at
the end of my work shift
right no crazy no no right have to be
I'm not putting this to the Democracy
either if you can't agree it goes to the
audience yeah no cuz they're going to
get I'm worried unfortunately that is
the format no there's a floor in the
game okay I let the facts speak I'm an
objective person I see the facts in
front of me I think Andy Cole he's got
more goals right he was a better Striker
so he wins no but that's that's not it
right ridiculous what we doing you're
voting Cole I'm not I'm not voting
anything I'm saying it
is it has to be Burham we're going to
the vote okay so burkam 1% of the vote
Andy Cole 0.25 so it is bur you guys
don't know it is Burham it's consider
wow four times crazy dang I was worried
there I shouldn't have been I should
have trusted you more sport Bible
audience hold on let's get back to your
side BV we got Aguero versus Van Percy
well it's easy he's got more Premier
League titles he's got a better goal to
game ratio he's far more consistent he
won the Premier League with multiple
managers boo is correct it is Aguero
over van persy there's very little to
done yeah right baby easy do the honors
Aguero goes through okay now we got
erling harand versus Harry Kane there's
very little to debate here either this
is easy just do it Booth okay yep Oh I
thought you going
there obviously we'll we'll do it quick
but it's it's Harry Kane we'll talk
about it all I can say is there is an
argument to be made that if he stays for
five six seven years I think it's it's
pretty straight yeah I'd agree with that
but yeah five years and if he does stay
do you think he breaks the Premier
League record he breaks every that yeah
he won't stay for that long though all
right nice and easy right we've got our
first semi-final Wayne Rooney versus
Dennis
Burham I think Dennis Burham has done
incredibly well to get here he's seen
off some great players but Rooney is
Rooney is Sensational and even the
Brilliance of burkham can't outweigh
interesting they're both non Strikers
really they're not pure pure Strikers
obviously they both dropped deep and and
Rooney was even a Winger at points and
and a midfielder so I think it's
interesting that's how good both of them
are to get that far in the tournament
they're not really they're not number
Nines in like Robbie fower is for
example all right this has to be Rooney
yeah happy with that yeah I think get
Rooney in the final first finalist Wayne
Rooney all right nice next one we have
got Kun Aguero versus Harry Kane it's so
hard to argue like I want to make a case
here but the the trophy Hall of Aguero
is is very difficult to compete with if
you know if Kane had had
titles I think it's Kane but he doesn't
and therefore it's almost irrelevant me
saying that isn't it I really want to
fight for him I think he's just a
glorious footballer but he hasn't given
me any ammunition I can't I can't make a
case for it five titles do you know how
brilliant you have to be to be in a
guard team for that long and and not be
replaced you know they were looking at
other players other Strikers came in and
he held on to his place regardless of
the money that they could spend
regardless of the other Strikers on the
on the horizon in World football they
could have signed anyone and it was
always Aguero um I can't argue yeah I
think it's pretty straightforward let's
do it then let's get Aguero this is
tough now I love this the Battle of
Manchester we've got Wayne Rooney versus
Sergio
Aguero if you think of all of the
attributes of both players I think Wayne
Rooney is at the very least as good at
Aguero as everything and then better
than him other things so in terms of in
terms of carrying the ball I think way
Rooney was a better Ball Carrier um I
think that he's as good a finisher I
think that his work rate is higher I
think that he did more for the team
overall and I think the answer just has
to be in fact the more I speak about it
the more I think that it just is Wayne
Rooney what do you think Bo I think
you're bang on in terms of the overall
player that Wayne Rooney is I can't I I
love I think he's the best player to
ever come out as country period in my
opinion aguera you probably could AR
argue he's top 10 from Argentina so
that's different the only thing I I
don't agree with is the finishing I
think we we saw more of Aguero in the
Box because he he was asked to play that
role I think Wayne Rooney's finishing
when he did have those long range
efforts the volleys and the bicycle
kicks of course but Aguero did it times
on with two in terms of the amount of
goals he got I mean what he number four
on the list of all time goal scorers in
the Premier League and obviously
Rooney's close as well but I think the
finish in Aguero is a better finisher of
the ball um but everything else I think
you know Ro Wayne Rooney is Manchester
United you think of some of the icons
that they've had playing up front
scoring goals for them he's Manchester
United's top goal scorer he's England's
top goal scorer and somehow some people
think his career was underwhelming
that's how good he was you know nobody
would ever argue that Aguero didn't
fulfill his potential but some people
would incorrectly in my opinion suggest
that way Rooney didn't necessarily
fulfill his potential so I thought that
when we came into this debate when we
actually explore it that it was going to
be way tighter but wayone is just a
better footballer and a better St and
he's won more Prem titles and he's won
more Prem 10 a kind of 10e spell sare is
close to eight nine years it's a little
bit longer as well yeah it's it's it's
Rooney yeah wow it's Rooney there you go
I thought it was going to be much harder
than that with if it was someone else if
it was you know even onri I think Aguero
can talk to onri about you know we have
a debate but because of Rooney's total
total play Then you had the goal records
then you had more Premier League titles
even the Champions League final he did
show up for Man United in champ
Champions League final as well I think
it's Roney yeah and that's the other
thing we saw Aguero crying in Portugal
didn't we why you have to bring that no
no no actually I go back go to the vote
now I just to bring that up I was crying
too right okay so please do the honors
Wayne Rooney is the greatest Premier
League striker of all time W
congratulations W congratulations
r
that Liverpool side were good though and
um the United side and I know you're not
United fans are going to come up come at
me now they had a lot of luck in that
treble and listen you need a lot of luck
to win these knockout competitions but
they had a good for death yeah they had
a lot of luck getting through but that
Liverpool side I remember that final man